he's Jay Bilas from the worldwide leader
in sports back here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Jay
I'm doing great rich over you well what
do you take out of all this just give me
the overview first what do you take out
Jay yeah there's lots on pack I mean
this is a bizarre situation that you're
gonna find not that there's you know
sort of mistreating in college athletics
course there is and that there's an
ungodly amount of money with the players
the most valuable commodity in the game
unpaid that there's going to be you know
if you want to call it corruption is
going to be breaking at these amateurs
rules but just the idea that the federal
government became involved and we're
talking about wider caps and
confidential informants so the people
involved in this are basically dead to
rights here and though there's no
disputing what happened as you would see
sometimes in a normal investigation well
in terms of that you know that the
people who are initially arrested in
something like this involving the feds
are not the ones that they're trying to
go after they're the ones that they're
they were easy to get and the ones that
you can squeeze to get bigger fish what
do you think other programs and coaches
across the country are thinking right
now Jake well it depends I mean you
haven't done anything or the piper and
the ones who have been wondering if if
they're gonna get ensnared in this right
and I don't know look I understand the
way the business works I know the
players have been paid forever on the
ingress you know the answer Double A was
founded in 1905 or so and it was founded
in scandal and operated at scandal ever
since you know you're not going to put a
bunch of amateurism rules in that are
going to limit only one aspect of the
game that being the players you know
essentially labor and expect that that
you're going to make millions of dollars
and everything's gonna be okay nobody's
going to violate the rules of course
they are and and so that's sort of where
the rub is in this thing and players
have been paid forever under the table
it's just that paid in different ways
and so this scandal may change the way
that money flows for the players but I
think it's it's laughable and naive to
think that in this multi-billion dollar
industry that even as unpleasant
this is to go through that this was
going to stop the flow of money it may
change the direction in which it flows I
mean yeah you remember that movie
Jurassic Park when Jeff Goldblum says
life will find a way well in NCAA sports
money will find a way and you never see
these scandals in Division two in 2003
because the the revenues and the
expenditures and the salaries are in
line with the stated mission of the
institutions in the pink one they are
not in line if you guys make it seven
eight nine million dollars a year and
you know Louisville has a hundred and
sixty million dollar contract with
adidas which pales in comparison to what
they're making from the ACC media deal
what their makes on the entry double
agent with these all these teams make
from the NCAA tournament college
football and all that stuff so we
haven't seen the last of these scandals
this is just the latest one well the
question is I have Jay Bilas in the
Honda insider report is why isn't there
enough of a push from the institutional
level from school presidents who for the
grace of God they can go with the the
interim president right now of
Louisville who's got this you know what
sandwich now sitting on his desk
why wouldn't they basically cuz and and
he had one of the all-time great winning
college basketball coaches at his
disposal why won't these guys take some
of the money and ladies who are in
charge of these institutions take some
of the money and create a police force
with teeth that in real time can monitor
these situations instead of what they
currently have Jay cuz it's not gonna
stop it it doesn't matter what you do
you know you can have a police force or
integrity monitors do whatever whatever
you are people are still gonna find a
way I mean these players are valuable
commodity and people are gonna find a
way to get them says the only way to win
is to get players and you can say you
can talk coaches all you want but no no
great coach wins without great players
you can lose with them but you cannot
win without them and everybody knows
that so that's the valuable commodity
and they're going to go out and get them
and in a in a in a system where you know
it is a cartel system where there's a
heel at erally imposed wage scale on the
player
and everybody can only offer a
scholarship and a stipend then of course
you're gonna offer more to get somebody
you know you don't hear these kind of
bribery scandals other type of scandals
with coaches because you can just offer
the contract and it should be the same
with players I mean it and then it would
get everything aboveboard and you know
they we wouldn't have this underground
economy and and there's really no reason
for this to me rich if they're old
enough to settle for billions of dollars
they're old enough to make money and we
know exactly who to recruit we know
exactly who to play in minutes of the
games we know exactly who the
all-americans are we know who to pay and
all these schools know exactly who to
pay they just don't want to do it they
want to keep all the money for
themselves and that's fine
go ahead but you're going to continue to
have these scandals and to think that
you're not is is painfully naive to the
point of laughs so then what's the fix
because I think everybody looks at this
and says it's it's it's disgusting it
makes you want a shower and and and
nobody really wants to think about this
sort of stuff and see it everybody just
wants to obviously turn on March Madness
and enjoy it but that's it so what is
the fix to this whole thing Jay if you
could wave a wand and fix the whole
thing well the fix is either start
acting like you talk and make this like
division 2 or division 3 and you know
act like the Masters does and don't have
make this a commercial enterprise
don't sign multibillion-dollar contracts
with television networks you have your
games at decent times don't travel your
players all over the world and all over
the country just to use them to make
money don't pay your coaches millions
upon millions of dollars to do this app
like they do in Division two in Division
three and keep your salaries and
expenditures and revenues in line with
your mission or if you're gonna if
you're gonna continue this multi-billion
dollar industry and in my experience
Richard yours too I'm sure you know
multi-billion dollar industries don't
just fold up and go away they're gonna
keep doing this if you're gonna keep
doing this and your players you know
there's nothing wrong and you know
there's nothing wrong with students
being paid because every other student
is allowed
to be paid every other student is
allowed to make money based upon their
name like this the talent level music
student scholarship you can make however
much money you want and still still be
enrolled in school and a student in good
standing if you're a if you're on a
scholarship as a as an English student
you can write a book you can write a
screenplay you can do you make as much
money as you want if you're a
scholarship in theatre you can do movies
you can make as much money as you want
and you're celebrated for that so why
would we restrict college athletes the
only ones that are bringing in the money
and then when when something happens
that we know is inevitable we want to
make it seem like everybody's a criminal
when they're not they're just trying to
do business in a multi-billion dollar
industry
look I don't condone breaking the rules
I certainly don't condone breaking the
law the rules didn't make anyone break
them I'm not suggesting that but the
rules get create this underground
economy so we can't be naive and then
and then somehow say how did this happen
it's been happening forever and it's
going to keep happening we can't just
put a new rule in and all of a sudden
it's going to stop you know I hate to go
back to this no life we'll find a way
but the money will find a way you know
we thought Wall Street we thought we
could stop you know we could change Wall
Street after the meltdown of 2008 how'd
that go you know we're not going to stop
the flow of money there either and and
we can regulate this if we allow the
players to participate in it to the
extent of their of their fair market
value couple more minutes with Jay Bilas
in the Honda insider report Jay Bilas
from ESPN here on the Rich Eisen show
Tom Creon's name is being batted around
as being an interim head coach for
Louisville once the inevitable comes in
that Pitino is officially let go do you
think he'd be interested in something
like that Jay I'm he would listen I mean
Tom's an outstanding coach he did a
great job at Marquette neighbors
assistance Tom Izzo and Michigan State
helped build that program up and do a
national power and then I thought did a
very good job in Indiana before poor ran
out of gas at the end there but I think
he would be a great call
you know Louisville didn't tough spot
right now the question is do they want
to get somebody on an interim basis they
want to get somebody that they tend they
keep full time
the full-time solution you bring him in
he'll continue that place I mean they're
gonna take a step back because of what
they got going on but I think doctrine
is be perfect right I mean he would be
but I mean why would it my my two cents
is why would he want to do that I mean
who knows what the heck's can happen
with Louisville's basketball program or
even the whole darn shooting match Pat
forty of y'all who thinks they should
get the death penalty Jay I mean I hear
that I respect that great leader great
friend a great fighter but they're not
going to do that I mean that was that
was the tool they used against us on you
I think they found that it was a career
option that was a I wasn't good for
anybody and now that they're cleaning
house and cleaning out everybody I have
any doubt that that Louisville because
there's great bones there and and it's
been a great program I think it'll be a
great program again but I don't I don't
believe that through knows we can all be
proven wrong in this thing because who's
ever pradipika at the NCAA is gonna do
but but I would not I would not
anticipate the death penalty coming
their way all right so last one for you
Jay crystal ball it for me what do you
think ends up happening over the next
week's months if not years to college
basketball in this country based on that
like yeah nothing over stuff like this
we got cheating scandals before with not
gambling scandal seemed like the world
was going to end every time that
happened there was that choice we may
have some issues that are you know some
regulation that comes in with regard to
how the money flows but it's still gonna
flow and it's still gonna they're not
gonna cancel 160 million dollar
contracts and they're not going to
cancel television contract they're gonna
play the game and all the money is going
to keep flowing in and everybody's gonna
keep making they got a bunch of contract
here they got on it so we're not seeing
any change we're just gonna hear a lot
of high-minded rhetoric and then we'll
go back to business as usual
so depressing check I think I'm gonna go
watch Jurassic Park and just roll up
into a ball that's what I'm thinking
what I mean I don't think it is
depressing I think it I think this is a
great game most people do the right
thing
but we got a phony system rich I mean we
can't sit here and pretend like this is
another golf or the Little League one
sherry the multi-billion dollar business
and the players are worth of tax money
and we think agents and and you know
quote unquote third parties aren't going
to try to get a piece of these guys of
course they are and the school will say
they're trying to protect them from
commercial exploitation when all they're
doing is commercially exploiting us you
know when you when you make money off
about the same time limiting that person
for making money you exploit them by
definition the players aren't mistreated
but they are exploited and any
reasonable economist would agree with
that
all right before I let you go ask him
the poll question Brockman go for it all
right Jay what is Rick Pitino's legacy
champion disgrace or both what do you
think Jake
I mean he's being fired industry I think
the you know his personal indiscretion
that he got five secured seven or eight
years ago and then the you know the
escort scandal on top of this is going
to be too much funny ones reputation
overcome that'll be right along with
champion cuz he's one of the greatest
coaches to ever live but but he won't
outlive exactly will not outlive you
know that reputation on this Jay you're
awesome man you're the perfect guest in
your your you're terrific at it and
you're terrific at everything you do
really appreciate you calling in Jake
always well great to be with you rich as
always you got it you gotta that's at
Jay Bilas on Twitter Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that download our app please
just if if it's a memory thing just
delete other refs you don't need those
apps this app the Rich Eisen show up you
need that